I love it shanté came out she was on the
show she came out Esther ku came out a
bunch of people came out we all went out
it was so much fun and there was a
little Korean comedian named moon we met
just moon the honored name was moon and
then H a was like Jake caterpillar open
for me she was like I want to eat her
[ __ ] I go what yeah eat her [ __ ] right
now sure that's at that that's fine
Nick she didn't say that sorry she did
as a joke yeah she's not gonna get mad
yeah but it was a great weekend and then
at the airport Jaden I had a very strong
laugh why was that but because she said
guilt gilbert is cute he's a cute guy he
was and he wasn't show the video god
damn it what do you mean because he's to
be effect that no I think yeah and so I
showed her the video of him fat dancing
on dancing in that you described you're
better with it right so if you look back
a couple months ago on her Instagram
there's a video of Gilbert doing a State
Farm commercial and he's doing he was
about 300 pounds was the best 300-pound
230 but let's 230 I'm not but he's only
like five seven so just basically yeah
some context there and he was doing some
like serious body rolls next to a car it
was one of those really cheesy very
Insurance commercials but that's what
yeah yeah I mean I you know you do a lot
I've done a lot of things in the past
that are embarrassing is the boy yo
chicken one the worst one you've done
yeah but that's not out there you can't
find it I hope you can if somebody can
find that commercial that'd be great
I did a El Pollo Loco commercial where I
was dance I did that you can dance in
the street with like it was one of those
ones where you know we're all in cars
and then all of a sudden the el pleito
some song comes out and every like the
cops comes off the bike
everyone's dead yeah and the old man you
know and we're all doing the chicken
dance and it was really embarrassing
because I was living in Silver Lake at
the time and next door to me was all
these kids that were the kids of and
thirteen gang members so you couldn't
really like argue with them you know
they would make fun of you they're like
12 and then when that commercial came
out I remember them gone yes ru and then
they all did the chicken dance making
fun of me and I was blushing and I felt
like so sad about it god yeah
I've done a lot of those kind of ones
that are embarrassing but
[Music]